bienvenidos supongamos que aquí tenemos
un resorte que está conectado a una
pared y digamos que bueno estamos viendo
que el resorte en este momento llega
aquí pero si este resorte estuviera en
su estado natural llegaría hasta acá si
yo no estuviera comprimiendo el resorte
éste llegaría hasta este punto en este
caso yo lo estoy empujando y tiene un
por lo tanto un desplazamiento en x
bueno en la horizontal llamado x
qué es este desplazamiento a la
izquierda lo primero que quiero hacer es
graficar qué tanta fuerza he aplicado en
diferentes puntos mientras comprimida
este resorte y quiero usar esa gráfica
para encontrar qué tanto trabajo hicimos
al comprimir comprimirlo
sólo vamos a ocuparnos de la magnitud
del desplazamiento no de la dirección
vamos a dibujar aquí una gráfica donde
tenemos un eje
de dónde vamos a poner la fuerza que se
ha aplicado y aquí en el eje x base es
el desplazamiento
en x
si normalmente resorte llega aquí
para desplazarlo hasta aquí qué tanta
fuerza tengo que aplicar tenemos que la
ley de hook nos dice
qué
la fuerza
de fuerza en el resorte va a ser igual a
menos que esta es la constante del
resorte por el desplazamiento por x la
fuerza restauradora es la fuerza que el
resorte aplica a cualquiera que lo
comprime la dirección del desplazamiento
es la misma que la fuerza que se está
aplicando resorte a esta fuerza la voy a
llamar la fuerza de compresión la que
estoy aplicando a cada voy a poner en
otro color la fuerza que se aplica al
alcalde voy a llamar fuerza de
compresión
es opuesta a la fuerza de restauración
así que mi fuerza de la compresión va a
ser igual a la constante positiva porque
es la dirección opuesta a la de
restauración multiplicada por el
desplazamiento
una vez que el resorte se ha comprimido
y no se está acelerando en ninguna
dirección la fuerza de compresión va a
ser igual a la fuerza de restauración
cuando llega aquí y ya no me estoy
moviendo no se está variando el
desplazamiento estas dos fuerzas van a
ser iguales en magnitud lo que quiero
graficar aquí es en realidad la fuerza
de compresión con respecto al
desplazamiento
cuando el resorte está en reposo va a
estar aquí está este punto
es cuando tengo mi desplazamiento cuando
es el desplazamiento natural mi x 0
cuando x es igual a cero así que no se
está desplazando cuentas de fuerza hay
que aplicar
si empujamos con un poquitito de fuerza
muy muy pequeña y se comprimiera un
poquito de resorte la fuerza de
compresión será muy cercana a cero
entonces estarían más o menos como por
acá
más o menos
para desplazar el resorte un metro qué
tanta fuerza tenemos que aplicar con
respecto aquí supongamos que aquí
desplace algo
un metro bueno entonces tenemos que es
la distancia aquí es un metro
y en la fuerza si fuera aquí uno
bueno la sustituye aquí este
espacialmente igual a 1 pues esta fuerza
de compresión es igual acá mi constante
del resorte entonces este valor sería
acá
y aquí tendría
aquí estaría graficando este punto y si
yo sigo aplicando poco a poco más fuerza
pues se va a ir desplazando más si yo
ahora quiero ver cuánta fuerza necesito
para desplazar
a dos metros el espaciamiento aquí es
dos pues es dos veces la constante
entonces aquí sería dos acá y más o
menos quedaría el punto en la gráfica
aquí
y pueden ver que se está formando una
línea que la voy a dibujar va a tratar
de dibujarla no más
y claro posible vamos a unir
estos puntos
y más o menos aquí día mi línea
imaginando que es una línea recta pero
como lo estoy dibujando a mano alzada no
está tan derecha
esto es cuánta fuerza se debe aplicar
como una función del desplazamiento del
resorte desde su estado natural y está
gráfica es la magnitud del
desplazamiento y no indica la dirección
vamos a pensar un poco en lo que ocurre
aquí si aplicamos una fuerza muy muy
grande pues el resorte se va a acelerar
mucho y se va a desplazar bastante
aunque normalmente se aplica la fuerza
poco a poco lo suficiente para superar
la fuerza de restauración
espero que con esto les quede un poco
más claro de cómo se ve cómo se
incrementa la fuerza proporcionalmente
en función de la distancia que se
comprime la suerte y esto se debe que
esta es una ecuación lineal y cuál es la
pendiente de esta de esta línea la
pendiente va a ser la altura sobre la
base suponiendo que mi altura
mi altura es de 1 metro
perdón mi altura es de un k
hola el valor de la constante del
resorte pues mi base
bases
de un metro
así que la pendiente
la pendiente de ésta
línea de esta gráfica vamos a escribirla
aquí
pendiente
va a ser igual
a la constante de la suerte y vamos a
usar esta gráfica para calcular cuánto
trabajo tenemos que hacer para comprimir
este resorte de x0 hasta con este valor
vamos a tomar a estas x
vamos a ponerle x0 este es x inicial
este es un x0 quiero saber cuánta fuerza
cuando trabajo tengo que aplicar para
llegar a desplazar hasta aquí mi resorte
entonces
cuál es la definición de trabajo
recordemos la fórmula de trabajo
trabajo w a ser igual a la fuerza por el
desplazamiento veamos cuánto es nuestro
desplazamiento
mi fuerza
si yo aquí desplace un metro
mi fuerza es este desplazarme está en
este desplazamiento por la fuerza la
fuerza llega más o menos hasta acá este
cuadrado será el trabajo
para desplazarme a la siguiente pequeña
distancia mi fuerza va a incrementar un
poco
aquí me estoy desplazando mi fuerza se
va a incrementarse
y va a hacer esto y como pueden ver yo
puedo ir incrementando la distancia y e
ir dibujando
aproximaciones
del trabajo que es buena la fuerza por
la distancia
estos rectángulos no llegan justo a la
línea de la mano así que la línea que me
está mostrando la función de la fuerza
con el desplazamiento por eso les digo
que son aproximaciones para conocer el
trabajo va a ser el área bajo esta curva
entonces tendría que hacer cada vez
rectángulos más pequeñitos
para hacer una mejor aproximación
de esta área bajo la curva de este
trabajo y bueno sé que pues todavía no a
lo mejor no lo hago conocen o no lo han
visto pero aquí estamos iniciando un
poco con conceptos de cálculo
de cálculo integral justamente pero
bueno si no lo conocen no se preocupen
entendamos que el trabajo que estamos
haciendo es el área bajo esta curva bajo
esta línea así que el trabajo que hago
al desplazar el resorte x cero metros es
el área de aquí acá toda esta parte
y es esta área bueno pues tenemos que es
un triángulo conocemos la base la base
es x0 la distancia
y la altura
este punto de aquí donde tenemos que es
bueno sus coordenadas son x0 como x 0 x
la constante del resort por acá que es
bueno lo que vimos que estaba
incrementando s
número de veces que aumentamos la
distancia por la constante de resorte
así que si es el área de un triángulo
vamos a tener entonces nuestra base x0
por la altura que es x 0 k y x 0
la constante por un medio lo dividimos
entre 2 y esto va a ser igual a un medio
de la constante por x0 al cuadrado y lo
que saben de cálculo los que saben de
cálculo sabrán que esto es igual a la
integral de x perdón de khan
x una distancia
con respecto a derivada de equis pero no
entraremos en detalles del cálculo para
no confundirlos para qué nos sirve esto
porque el trabajo necesario para
comprimir este resorte
es lo mismo que la energía potencial que
tiene almacenada este resorte si yo les
dijera que tengo un resorte y que la
constante del resorte
la constante de este resorte es igual a
y que no comprimir una distancia
de 55 metros o centímetros al momento de
estar comprimido cuál sería su energía
potencial
su energía voy a cambiar de color
su energía
potencial
bueno la energía potencial será igual a
la mitad
de la constante
de acá
por la distancia
x
sustituimos los valores tenemos la
energía potencial es igual a un medio
que es 10
de 10 x x que es 5
50 entre 2 la energía potencial va a ser
igual a 25
perdón me equivoqué y apenas me di
cuenta es nuestra energía potencial va a
ser igual
ah
esto que les puso aquí pero la distancia
es al cuadrado entonces este valor no va
a ser igual a 5 x 555 al cuadrado 5 por
5 25 por 10 250 por lo que voy a borrar
esto
mi resultado es
d
250 entre 2 va a ser igual a ciento
125 va a ser mi energía potencial
almacenada en un resorte de estas
características comprimido esta
distancia
así que esto es lo que hay que recordar
se los voy a
resaltar aquí la energía potencial es
igual a este valor en un resorte
con esto tenemos el trabajo necesario
para comprimir el resorte y una vez
comprimido en ese punto o alargado en
ese punto pueden conocer su energía
potencial y conociendo esto podremos
resolver problemas con energía potencial
en resortes lo que haremos en el
siguiente vídeo